i have an announcement gentlemen oh go
on like i think
after 10 12 13 years
i may may have a new best girl of all
time oh
wait who was it before sanji kahara oh
so so ever since i like white bread too
so ever since the very first time i've
watched bucky monogatari yeah like
sanjay kahara has been
my waifu yeah you know enemy it's she's
always been the top tier girl
yeah and like people have come close but
no one where you go but no one has come
close to dethroning her but recently i
caught up to the renter girlfriend manga
and i think
that like chizuru is in contention for
being like my
best girl of all time really yeah
which like leads me to the question like
when like when did you first
know that you had like us like a a best
girl because i know who's yours is joey
yeah
and that nightcon is losing his mind
this question
this is like when people like on the
forums like how did you know you were in
love like what
made you feel like you're in love was it
like the stomach what is love
what is love and when did you first fall
in love
oh yeah i mean first of all i'm
surprised that shinjuku hara was like
your waifu because i
always thought it was [ __ ] oscar
i mean like us asaka was someone who i
could just respect for connor's conus is
dying in his corner here isn't my wife
she
she's just someone i respect she doesn't
ask her like 15
no no she i mean depends
well this is the biggest no officer
she's a drawing i mean
if we i don't know if i want to open up
that debate because that debate is a
[ __ ]
landmine of uh takes yeah but
yeah i mean like we can open that up i
don't know if i want to make it
i'm in the
you don't need a defense to be like yes
this is my girlfriend i don't care what
you think i love her i mean i
i don't think it's like a i'm not trying
to there's the people who are like yeah
it's pedophilia yeah i'm like
i don't know about that that's true but
like i think there's gonna be something
a little suss about being like yeah
they're my wife
yeah i'm not gonna willingly you know
walk into a courtroom and being like
here is like here inside the fans
your honor she was a drawing yeah which
you know like okay
your honor i have a birth certificate
she's technically 900
like i i do think there's a huge
difference in like having a waifu
and you know like sexualizing that's
true okay
waifu is like a character who is a
female i guess most of the time yeah
just really dig
yeah i get that i get that yeah and for
me it's always been senjighara
um just because i like from watching
bakumanagathi like i love the
personality
and why huh why um that was the biggest
huh
huh it's like how dare you even question
how dare you
even know what so i can you know think
of some excuses when i need to protect
myself um just because
like her interactions with araragi were
some of the most
entertaining react like interactions i
had seen in anime up to that point
um i think it was like the way she was
written and
the way like it really what really
solved me on the show
was basically sanjukar's reaction
interaction with aragi
and how their romance developed and how
her character was explored as well
it was it was just something that like
her character art just really resonated
with me and i think that's what really a
wifey is it's
it's a character who really like
resonates with you on a personal level
like you don't necessarily view them as
a life partner or anything like that
you're just like
damn man you're just it's just a
character that whatever they do
you just [ __ ] laugh yeah like they
can say or do anything and just how they
react
it's just like the highest tier of
symmetry and joey heard and saw all of
that and was like nah give me the one
who sucks my neck
nice character development bro how about
you suck my neck senzu kahara
is not my waifu but i [ __ ] love her
as a character yeah like i love how
everything she does and says is deadpan
as [ __ ] yeah that's what i love about it
it's her deadpan delivery and deadpan
humor which really drew her to like
drew her to me and then it was exploring
another side of the character her more
vulnerable side which
which made me like okay i'm simping i
want you to be happy
you know what i mean yeah okay i totally
guess i'll take that bruce
yeah he's really good at that though
that's why there's so many wife is yeah
but no i agree it's like every time like
chernobyl like his shot came on screen
like everything she said and did i was
just like i [ __ ] love it
i don't know why i can't explain it to
you in words i just i just love it
that powerful that when you're done
watching it you're like thinking about
it i mean
yeah yeah it's like he's such a good
character have you had never had a
character like why if we were not like
female not that you've just like kind of
resonated with you can have a husband as
well yeah i have a husband
yeah i think so i think so i don't know
i can't name him
off the top of my head i don't know uh
yeah i know i can't really think of any
immediately do you have a husbando
um i'd have to think about it because my
my husbando is a usui from kaichour made
somewhere
oh okay i hate guy yeah i said maylene's
like all right
that's a good choice okay what's it
called in english that show kaijo made
summer is uh president
is the is a maid it's really i don't
think i've seen that
do you want to explain his character
okay so usually is like the i guess so
kaiju made some is a it's based off a
shojo manga
from like the early 2000s i believe and
the animes from like the early 2000s but
basically
uh it's the story about like how the the
school uh
like class president basically is like
you know
normally the anime trip of class
president is like you know that they're
very like
hearted they're very like together you
know they're very adult for their age
kind of thing
but uh this particular uh kaiju
is also a maid at a maid cafe and she
gets the guy yeah so basically it's like
a complete opposite right
and so basically she gets found out by
this like [ __ ] hunk of a dude called
usu who like all the girls [ __ ] love
yeah and so it's this like special
relationship where he's trying to hide
the fact that she's
not actually this like all together like
me type personality
and she [ __ ] hates usu for it but of
course with how every shoujo manga goes
she's like actually i think i like this
guy i might like this guy
and then he's also like you know i kind
of started off you know just like just
teasing her but yeah she's she's kind of
hot